[Musique]
nourri par la philosophie rasta farraj
black nation est un artiste engagé dans
son dernier album la force déjà il
propose un reggae roots
nous allons parler avec lui ici au
bernica home & home et aux médias merci
black nation accueil a noté alan où les
giants et sa montée ryan ok mais dans
mon coin c'est qu'elle est appréciée
c'est là qu'est maintenant mon
inspiration c'est là qu'elle est sortie
le reggae
dites nous que yi la misère
rien
sa parole
[Musique]
comme on l'a aimé cette musique là comme
on l'a découvert ce courant là vous êtes
seul souhait c'est quelque chose est
vivant et ça vient d'eux de dia sa
mission qui est il va donner moi quoi et
qu'y saout et écoute quand il a commencé
à découvrir cette musique là bas
monsieur tintin musée qu'avant elle
avait au siège lentilles etc
j'ai découvert après marley
[Musique]
il a
[Applaudissements]
là
si l'on présente bob marley pot d'étain
cela ramène beaucoup de messages que
l'âme elle l'a fait découvert la musique
reggae au moins ça c'est un message et
un messager et a aussi ou d'autres
musiques ou passe des messages positifs
et aussi des messages rebelles cossa
l'important peau de faire passer
c'est important pour moi passer c'est
serré fait passer mon message celui de
l'amour mais ça à zapper il sait quoi
tirer volta où justement à 20 politique
et tout ça qui me voit la misère et des
crs aussi c'est indiqué souffrance
revient les sauriens d'esclaves aussi ça
soit la source
donc pour moi c'est révoltant mais
militants à travers les ai coupés ou
permanent vous fait découvrir est la
vérité c'est aussi une mission
spirituelle quand on joue la musique
reggae amis comme jamais effrayé les
spirituels blâmer d'un côté mollet avec
le scenihr milliards
[Musique]
on va
et quand on parle de révolution rasta
farraj kosovo diano révolution
l'appareil sa mission qui est des
jardins à nous à cet appareil c'est que
c'est nous on est choisi pourquoi vos
mains d'amour dans dans la set société
mais c'est bien dommage que nous reste à
faire
on est divisés chacun ce soir on l'a des
rastas ici on a plein on a même la
culture dont convient
un sou lire
s'il avait un message pour passer que ça
vous dirait aux réunionnais dans mon
message que veut faire passer aux années
ben il faut il faut arrêter de l'amour
il faut arrêter dans la paix il faut
être tolérant
merci beaucoup black nation d'avoir que
yann où il d'avoir partagé ce moment
avec nous parce que rohmer c'est aussi
de bien être là pour pouvoir nous un
soutien quoi